Battery's the most precious
resource to Android users
right now.
The world is more mobile,
but it's frustrating
when you can't make
it through the day
without needing a
recharge of your phone.
And sadly for most
developers, battery efficiency
is the last thing
on their minds.
My name is Colt McAnlis
canvas and the truth
is that your app doesn't
have to be a battery hog.
With a few simple
APIs and tools you
can have a fast, awesome
application that users love.
But let's take a step
back for a second.
How bad is the state of
battery usage right now?
Well, Purdue University did a
study of the top apps and games
for mobile devices, in which
they measured the battery
draw of various
types of actions.
They made a shocking discovery.
On average, only
about 25% to 30%
of the battery used
by these applications
was dedicated to the core
functions of the app,
like drawing images, laying
out news, or throwing birds
across the screen.
The other 75%--
completely eaten up
by uploading analytics,
checking location,
and constantly polling the
server for ads to display.
This finding presents
an interesting problem
for developers.
See, these applications
are effectively
eating up their users'
battery for their benefit
while only providing marginal
features to the users, which
is tricky since at
the end of the day
the user's happiness
is directly linked
to the success of
the application.
Smart developers
will focus on finding
a balance between
these two extremes
by recognizing that they
can perform the same actions
and draw less battery
at the same time.
For example, waking up
the device from sleep
has a battery cost
associated with it.
So conservative
use of wake locks,
or rather smarter
can help reduce battery drain.
Likewise, some operations
don't have to happen right now.
For example, uploading
songs, recalculating storage,
or resizing your photos
should probably not
be done while the user is out
in the middle of their holiday
shopping, right?
And network requests are
another big drain on battery.
See, each time you turn on
your phone's mobile radio
it has to keep itself awake
for a few seconds in case
a response packet comes in.
Of course, needing to draw extra
battery just to stay awake.
So if you're polling
an ad server every five
seconds or so, you're going
to be incurring the cost
over and over and over again.
Thankfully Android has several
tools to help you track down
and fix these battery issues.
Firstly, you can get by battery
data stats on the device
by going to Settings,
and then Battery,
and then choosing the
application you're
interested in.
You'll notice that the data
reporting on this screen
is mostly about how long
your device is awake,
and its networking connectivity.
And to dig deeper you can use
the battery historian tool
to get a graphical
view of how your app is
using the battery over time.
And once you've found
your app's issues,
Android has several APIs
that can help you fix them.
For example, using
the jobscheduler API
allows your application to
defer various types of work
to a time when the
battery is better
to be used, like
when it's plugged in,
or when it's connected
to the Wi-Fi,
or the next time it wakes
up the device intentionally.
So if you're looking to
optimize your application
to be lean on battery
check out the rest
of the Android performance
patterns resources
to get more info on
saving every last piece
of this precious
resource for your users.
So as always, keep calm,
profile your code, and remember,
perf matters.